Samuel leaves here and I'm gonna be
taking a lot of questions down the line
in fact one of the things I'm thinking
of doing on this channel is actually
giving people an opportunity to ring up
and speak to me live and I'll give you
God I'll give you a little bit of
coaching and answer your questions on
the spot specifically for you so if that
sounds like a good idea and you'd like
to do that then please just give this
video a comment with your questions also
give me a thumbs up that would be
fantastic and I'm gonna hit you with the
question that someone asked me just
yesterday so stay tuned for that so the
latest question that I've had and this
was actually not on the youtube comment
this was on the Facebook group that we
have if you're not part the Facebook
group you can get on it just put in
Facebook property investors with Samuel
Leeds but the question was and I get
this a lot and that's why I'm gonna
answer this right now the question was
what advice would you give to a 19 to 22
year old aspiring property investor my
advice is this one stop referring to
yourself as a 19 to 22 year old to stop
referring to yourself as aspiring
property investor and just get on with
it
as a professional property investor and
what did I say that I just I feel like
there's a lot of people and they label
themselves and put themselves in boxes
which makes it more difficult for them
so rather than saying oh I'm a twit
I don't care I don't care you're 22 like
that's not relevant what you're actually
saying in saying that is saying oh it's
difficult for me because I'm young it's
not difficult for you because you're
young and the word aspiring I'm an
aspiring property investor what's that
what that's saying is it's saying I'm
not a property investor if you're going
around saying I'm not a property
investor oh and I'm young you basically
just dooming yourself instead what you
need to do is you need to say oh I'm a
property investor not I'm 22 not I'm
aspiring it's a mentality thing but when
I started out I was super young when I
went to my first property networking
event I was 17 and I did my first deal
that year I didn't go and say I'm 17 I
went and said I'm a property investor
I'm aspiring you just get on with them
do it that's kind of my advice so that's
certainly what not to do what to do what
I've done a video called
seven steps for property beginners I'd
recommend checking that out just above
my head if you've got questions popping
below I'll do my best to answer them if
I really like the question we could
maybe set up a call or something and
we'll film it see you next time
subscribe god bless you thank you so
much for watching if you benefited from
that video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time